who here a year or two ago thought that
they'd be living through a global
pandemic
a new virus that spread across the world
and killed millions
one of the scariest things about this
virus is that when it broke out we are
next to no cures or treatments to fight
against coven 19
but viruses new and old aren't our only
worries
from infectious bacteria that have
become immune to our antibiotics to
increase rates of cancers humanity is
struggling to find solutions to our ever
evolving medical needs
to find our medicines of the future
we're turning to mother nature for help
my name's sam afflues and i'm an
underwater alchemist
but instead of turning lead to gold
i'm turning ireland's hidden treasure
deep sea coral reefs into our medicines
of the future
for thousands of years we have turned to
natural remedies made from the plants
and animals that surround us to cure us
of our ailments
put your hand up if when you have a cold
or a cough use natural treatments like
honey or ginger to help relieve your
symptoms
hot whiskies
the reason why these natural remedies
work is they rely on molecules called
specialized metabolites that are mainly
produced by organisms that can't move
like plants and mushrooms to defend
themselves from diseases and predators
over the past 200 years scientists have
traveled to the four corners of our
world
in search of organisms that may contain
these medicinal molecules
this fundamental research has resulted
in over half our medicines today being
derived and inspired by natural sources
although these scientists scoured the
surface of our planet for organisms with
these potential medicines there was one
area that remained underexplored and it
just so happened to be the biggest part
the oceans
our oceans cover over three quarters of
the earth's surface and contain the most
biodiverse ecosystems on our planet
in ireland we own eight times more ocean
than we do land and it's filled with
forms of life that seem alien to us
all of these creatures you see here i
photographed in irish waters along the
conimara coastline and you can discover
them for yourselves if you visit rock
pools or snorkel through the kelp
forests
when jack cousteau invented scuba diving
in the 1940s this provided scientists
with the tools required to explore these
diverse ecosystems
now they could spend hours underwater
uncovering hundreds of new species from
colorful corals to spectacular sponges
of all shapes and sizes
when chemists got their hands on these
samples and started analyzing the
molecules that these animals made they
were amazed new molecules many of which
chemists taught would be impossible to
form
but then mother nature had something to
say
when they tested the potential of
turning these new molecules into
medicines
they found that many of these new
molecules could kill the most potent of
drug resistant bacteria destroy the most
virulent of cancers and even be used to
treat pain
there are 17 medicines today in your
local pharmacies and hospitals that are
derived from marine sources
sorry
one of these medicines in particular
zucconetide
was isolated from the conus magnus also
known as the magical cone snail
what's magic about this sea snail isn't
just its beautiful shell and pattern but
one of the natural molecules it produces
is such an effective painkiller that
it's a thousand times stronger than
morphine
and you're probably asking yourself
why would a sea snail produce something
that's a thousand times stronger than
morphine
is that why they're slow
and the answer
ingenious evolution
see these sea snails hunt fish and they
don't have the speed to chase down their
prey like a lion hunter gazelle
so instead they harpoon their prey
injecting it with a potent mixture of
neurotoxins like sacconate that
paralyzed the fish instantly
it's the kona tide's ability to target
the nervous system of vertebrates like
us
that makes it such an effective
painkiller
and while scuba diving was a
revolutionary leap forward allowing
scientists to study our coastal marine
ecosystems
our oceans extend far past our shores to
unimaginable depths
we can only dive so deep before the
physical pressure pressing down causes
lethal effects this left the vast
majority of our oceans under explored
more people have been to space than have
been to our ocean's deepest steps
to find our medicines of the future
we went to explore these depths on the
research vessel the celtic explorer
and sailed south from irish shores to
some of the largest geographical
features that scar our planet
submarine canyon systems like widard
canyon where the sea floor drops from
300 meters to 3 000 meters
and it's here
in some of the most extreme
environmental conditions in the world
that deep sea coral reefs flourish
conditions at these depths are so
extreme we have to use a
state-of-the-art robotic submarine the
size of a minibus to collect our samples
and when i say extreme conditions i
really mean extreme
unlike the coral reefs that the cone
snails inhabit
instead of the water being warm and
tropical it's the same temperature as
your fridge
instead of it being bright clear and
sunny it's pitch black and has never
seen the light of day
permanently bathed in eternal darkness
and instead of being able to swim around
freely if you were to dive to these
depths you would be crushed in seconds
with the sheer pressure
equating to the weight of 20 elephants
standing on your head
even with these harsh conditions deep
sea coral reefs are among the most
biodiverse ecosystems in the world
rivaling that of the great barrier reef
and the amazonian rain forest
in this one picture alone there are
hundreds of unique species from starfish
to sea fans cup corals to crinoids all
of which have adapted over millions of
years to thrive in this unforgiven
environment
many of these animals are new to science
and remain in the final frontier in
studying life on our planet
some of these animals are so alien like
deep sea jellyfish that they even
inspired the creatures in james
cameron's avatar after the director
explored the deep sea
this abundance of biodiversity creates
competition especially between the
filter feeding animals to fight for
space to grow as far out into the water
current as possible
to catch as much food as possible
for millions of years this battle for
space and food has raged on in the
darkness resulting in some of the most
beautiful biological creations our world
is yet to see
and this is an example of some of that
beauty
a two meter wide trumpet sponge we found
at a depth of 1.5 kilometers
this species of sponge has evolved to
grow an intricate skeleton of interwoven
glass fibers that stretch out into the
current
but
this beauty
comes with the dark side
it turns out the battle for the sponges
and corals to survive and thrive
is a battle that relies on chemical
warfare
my aim
is to isolate these chemical weapons
which we can then utilize in our own
fights against microbes and cancers
if you look closely at this sponge there
are these tiny yellow dots
each of those yellow dots is a
coral-like animal growing on the sponge
using it as a scaffold to feed in the
current
this can negatively affect the sponge so
in a response the sponge and its
microbiome produce toxic compounds to
kill the corals and in a response to
that the corals produce their own toxic
compounds to kill the sponge
it's these compounds we aim to develop
into new anti-cancer therapies and
future antibiotics
but these reefs contain thousands of
species and each species may contain
thousands of molecules so you might
imagine that finding the one that could
be a cure for a type of cancer or might
stop the next pandemic would be like the
proverbial finding a needle in a
haystack
in the dark
but the same way that we soak berries
and spices in alcohol to make gin
we soak our corals and sponges in
alcohol to make coral and sponge gin
which we call extract
we then feed this extract to different
diseases cancers malaria viruses even
brain eating amoebas and we waste
most of the time
nothing happens
but
every once in a while
one of these extracts manages to kill a
disease
letting us know it contains a natural
molecule with the potential to be turned
into a medicine
we then isolate these molecules and test
them against the disease again
until we find the one
the one molecule that has resulted from
millions of years of evolution in our
oceans dark depths that we can now use
in our own wars against cancers bacteria
and viruses
but once we find these medicines we
can't just rip these animals from the
reef as our source
that would destroy the very vital
biodiversity and result in competition
that created these molecules in the
first place
we don't need to come up with a complex
mechanism for manufacturing them in a
lab some of these molecules are so
complex we couldn't even if we tried
but mother nature has done the hard work
for us
hidden in the dna of these animals and
their associated microbes are the genes
or are the genes which carry the
biological recipes for producing these
molecules
using cutting edge techniques we can
take these genes and insert them into
microbes like yeast allowing us to grow
them in a bioreactor getting the
microbes to do the hard work for us
producing our medicines in a sustainable
cost-effective way without the need for
harsh chemicals such as heavy metals
that can be required in more traditional
manufacturing processes
our research isn't just to help protect
the health of humanity but also to
protect the health of these hidden reefs
deep sea reefs wrap around our entire
planet and already over half the reefs
that exist have been destroyed turned to
lifeless rubble by trawling and long
line fishing
with new threats in the horizon like
deep sea mining they're in more danger
now than ever before
by proving that their unique
biodiversity can be a natural resource
for providing us with new medicines
not only does this give a public health
incentive to protect these reefs but a
financial one also
like how safari tours provide the
economic incentive to conserve savannah
ecosystems
potential profits from pharmaceutical
sales could provide the financial
sustainability to explore and protect
these reefs
we need new medicines today more than
ever before
and the incredible biodiversity that
deep sea reefs offer have created a
fantastic library of natural molecules
which we can develop into our future
medicines
already our research group has found
potential medicines against asthma
malaria and even covet 19
showing the unbelievable potential of
these reefs
to protect our own health
we need to protect the health of deep
sea coral reefs
our future pharmacies
are hidden in our seas
thank you